throw a zombie head at a fascist and
storm the beaches of Normandy because we
have the finale of The Walking Dead
Daryl Dixon and I got to say this show
has been quite the ride there's a lot to
talk about in this video from the return
of Carol kon's decision and whether or
not Daryl will head back to America or
stay in France now this video is going
to be a bit different than my previous
ones with more of an emphasis on
theories than recap and I've left time
stamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be covering that being said
make sure to like And subscribe as we
take a look at some of the finale's
biggest events the beginning of the
episode actually begins with a flashback
from World War II here we see Daryl's
grandfather William Dixon dead on the
beaches of Normandy the Dixons have a
history of Abandonment from their
fathers William died in the war Daryl's
father was barely around and now Daryl
will abandon lauron as Isabelle says you
think you're escaping history by doing
this but you're
not you're ping it Daryl isn't exactly
jovial about his grandfather's sacrifice
bitter that it left his grandmother and
family shattered back home what Daryl
fails to see is that sometimes
sacrifices need to be made in order to
fight for a greater cause his
grandfather fought against fascism
something Jana looks to be bringing back
it's a bit ironic that his grandfather
stormed the beaches of Normandy while
Daryl fights to leave them that is until
he sees Lon the finale leaves us with a
decision will Daryl go back to America
or will he stay in France I actually
think there are three scenarios and I'll
outline which one I think the writers of
the show will go with first we have
Daryl going back to America without
luron I don't think this is going to
happen it would be a shitty thing to do
to luron and works against the Carol
plot of her searching for Daryl that
whole plot line would be kind of useless
if he just shows up back in America next
season the second scenario is Daryl
taking lauron with him to America Lon
did ask Daryl if he could come with him
but let's be real this whole Union
depends on Lon being with them to fight
Jana plus if season 2 is back in America
we lose one of the greatest things about
this show in an interview executive
producer Greg nikoo said that part of
the fun of setting this show in France
were all the cool new locations they
could explore we're talking aby's
castles the Eiffel Tower catacombs if we
go back to America we lose all these
cool things from both a story and
character standpoint I think the best
decision the writers can make here is
having Daryl stay in France with luron
this way we can continue the Jana
storyline while simultaneously having
Carol be the one to find Daryl I think
this opens up a lot of cool new
opportunities will Carol go directly to
France will she make a stop in England
I'd love to see her have a detour in
London so we can explore cool places
there maybe she'll even make some allies
to help in the Union's fight against
Jana speaking of Carol let's talk about
her in an episode 5 flashback we learned
that Daryl promised to Carol he'd be on
his way back he tells her that he's a
couple miles outside of free Port Main
and if you look behind the biker at the
end of episode 6 we'll see she's hot on
Daryl's tracks even finding this dude
riding Daryl's bike the same bike he was
riding the day he left Carol he must
have picked it up shortly after Daryl
was imprisoned and sent to the tanker
the biker tells Carol that he picked the
bike up at an encampment near a gas
station and that is exactly where Daryl
was before he was captured no doubt
Carol will soon learn of Daryl's fate
which will lead her overseas we also
don't get any further information on
Carol's radio message the one where she
said blank came back some of the
theories I've heard on who came back are
Rick Michonne Morgan and Dwight but it's
possible she's not referring to a person
at all she could have said it came back
as user St East on Reddit theorizes she
might have said ezekiel's sick it came
back referring to his cancer perhaps the
biggest WTF moment of the episode
revolves around kon's decision to save
Daryl and kill Jana's men I found this
out of character for a guy who's been
hunting Daryl the entire season who just
a few hours ago was basking in the idea
that today would be Daryl's last day on
Earth today you died but the writers
have yet again managed to provide a few
explanations for this decision when
interrogated by Jan kadon says that he
could not kill a child re e luron that I
could understand but why not kill Daryl
maybe this damages his story that they
were ambushed and outnumbered if Daryl
were to be killed maybe he knows they'll
need Daryl for the rest of the Trek to
the nest but the explanation I find most
interesting is more Supernatural there's
a saying in writing called DSX Mao
basically it's a term for when an
unsolvable problem is suddenly resolved
by an unexpected intervention in this
case the unsolvable problem is facing
imminent death by C and it's resolved by
his sudden change of heart this divin
likee intervention may have something to
do with lauron throughout the season the
show has played with us on whether or
not luron is really this second coming
of Christ and this scene is no exception
right before kadon is about to kill him
lauron says God loves you then Kon
changes his mind was this a literal Act
of divine intervention Jan tells Kon
that it will only get more painful as
he's taken away by the guards is she
implying that he could be one of the
scientists next test subjects speaking
of experiments Daryl and Quinn's Battle
with the variant zombies gave us several
more clues on what might actually be
happening in episode 5 we learned that
Jana was bringing zombies from America
to be tested on in France this may have
something to do with the zombies in
France being of a variant nature
Isabelle calls them Bron their blood
acts as some sort of acid in her big
speech last episode and I'm paraphrasing
here Jana talked about how the cure for
these zombies must come from the zombies
themselves we see one of the variant
zombies who is injected with this
unknown serum immediately attack and
kill another zombie is Jana's plan to
create this kind of super zombie that
can wipe out other zombies earlier in
the season as well as in the finale we
see how the serum only lasts a few
seconds before killing its host
obviously these experiments need a lot
more time to perfect but I think it
would be a great fail safe to have these
super zombies spontaneously combust
after a few minutes imagine unleashing a
few of these souped up zombies on that
horde underneath the Eiffel Tower when
the job was all done those super zombies
just explode it seems the only thing our
scientist needs to do now is make it
last longer one thing I am disappointed
about this season is its lack of a
connection to the French creation of the
virus in the first place I thought this
season would Center more around Daryl
getting to the bottom of this virus
since it's heavily implied the outbreak
started at a lab in Paris if you could
find out where the virus began Maybe
maybe it could give us Clues on how to
cure it this was part of the reason
Maggie tasked Daryl on this mission in
the first place to find out what's out
there I also wanted more backstory
behind the big antagonist Jan why is she
the way she is the writers have kind of
hinted that she used to be a mother
perhaps even losing a child I'd love to
see a flashback of her life before the
outbreak that explains why she's turned
into this fascist who says she'll do
unspeakable things if it means the
future generation doesn't have to we
learned that she used to kns at a museum
where she'd see paintings stare at her
suggesting she was a night security
guard this is pretty interesting
considering her disdain for art
specifically impressionism when talking
with Quinn in episode 4 impressionism
it's degenerate art I suspect season 2
will ramp up the feud between the union
and her Army those are all the big
topics I wanted to cover in this video
now I turn it over to you what are your
biggest thoughts and theories I want to
hear them in the comments below thanks
for watching for more takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram @
thinkstory YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very
much